hi how are you doing today
how are you i'm good thank you
what are the challenges when you're
crafting a performance where you're not
only singing but you're largely singing
your character's emotions and so how
does that come together
well it's a good question actually
because
um
you cannot let go all your emotions when
you sing because then you cannot sing
it cuts your breath
which is also interesting and that's
what leos carrax was
expecting because when he decided um
to do this movie he decided that we
would sing live
all the movie like usually when you do
musicals you you record songs in a
recording studio and then on set you lip
sync
um
so you know that you're always gonna
have a good singing
because you like validated uh the song
in the studio here because it's all live
um
it was kind of stressed out stressful
but at the same time what we um what you
can feel with the with the music that
conveys some uh the emotion like nothing
else
um
it was it was very deep
to find the right balance
between your emotion and the singing and
also everything that we did while
singing
like when you sing a song in a movie or
on stage your whole body is involved in
the singing and it doesn't do anything
else but singing
but in the movie we had to do many
things i had to do many things while
singing like
swimming or um you know uh sleeping or
um
even smoking a cigarette while singing
that was the worst actually i have to
say to find like the
the right time to like take the i mean
it was
but
that made the project so unique and you
really like uh reach the authenticity
of the emotion it was even interesting
to not be able to sing anymore and to
make something out of it
um because moving so much
um
keeps you from like singing like uh
uh in tune all the time or with the
right breathe all the time and it was
very interesting yeah to find the
balance to actually deliver
uh the emotion and at the same time
the music
so it sounds like this was a really
different experience than let's say la
vie and rose and singing in that film
well lavion rose i didn't sing
okay it was it was eddie piaf um
which was actually one of the hardest
thing i've ever done is lip syncing
to the perfection
where people will actually believe that
you are singing i had seen movies well
where uh actors were
lip-syncing on another voice and it
didn't work and i really wanted it to
work so i heard
a lot on the lip sync um
but yeah well
different from another musical i did
this musical with rob marshall a few
years ago called nine right and uh well
it was different because i didn't have
on set to think about my singing because
it was already recorded and i just had
to like live the song and and also it
was my voice so it was my breathing
without thinking of how i'm gonna
breathe you know
um
uh
but
singing live
is something that is very special
very very special and i i actually loved
it
did you uh work with any sopranos just
as a research just to sort of get in
sort of their head and what their world
is like to sort of understand
what anne's life is like as a performer
yeah
yeah i was lucky to uh meet with uh two
sopranos and i followed them uh
um
rehearsing
um and and i asked a lot of questions
um
and uh it was it was very interesting
to uh to talk to them
and to see how
they um actually one one thing that was
very interesting um
that all the singers i met said
that it's really weird for them to look
at themselves while they're singing
because they have this kind of face that
is too much everything is too much
everything is is wide and big and
um
and they told me that they would look
like monsters
and i thought that was very interesting
because yes when you see an opera singer
they have those faces because every
muscles is involved um
is involved in the singing so they
shared a lot with me a lot of their
routine
um a lot of their
feelings and how they
convey emotion while singing when you
cannot cry when you sing it will keep
you from singing so this emotion that is
there and that is only
um
shared through the voice
and um and i
i didn't know much about opera and i
went to the opera the first time of my
life while preparing this movie
and the voice and the power
of the body
releasing that
um
that voice that is that reaches
perfection and excellence
is absolutely
it's it's an experience
that i had never lived before like just
by a a voice and the power of the voice
and the emotion of the voice
being like
taken
by this emotion it was
it was really a very deep experience
i mean the film seems to show her as
that kind of singer that's someone that
can transport people and that sort of is
what pushes part of henry's jealousy
yeah she what yeah she's gifted
and um
and what she does really moves people
deeply
and um
and this is
this is this talent
that she has and and what's in herself
like an artist
uh the
the first material of an artist is
who he is or who she is
what she or he has to share
is
is you know this
this human being that that we are
um
and it's
um
i find it
very moving to do a movie um
about artists
and this
need of recognition that we all have i
mean we all
come with this need of recognition when
you
um when you're a kid you need to be
recognized by your parents by your
family but your
brothers and sisters and then you grow
up you need to be recognized
sorry by your friends by the people
you're surrounded with and an artist has
this like deep deep need of recognition
of
we need to be
heard we need to be looked at we need to
be
loved and um
and how how it affects us how it
affects um the people around us
um when you get this recognition and or
when you don't get it how this
frustration will
um
you know will
take your
yeah will affect people around you
basically
um
i thought that was uh one of
the most interesting themes in the movie
for me because i faced this question
uh because um
i'm an artist and uh
and i need to be recognized i need to be
loved and how do you live with this how
do you live when you had the recognition
and you don't have it anymore how do you
live with this need of recognition that
is not fulfilled by rick recognition i i
think this is a very very interesting
theme
well that that was a great answer and i
i think i have to leave it there
unfortunately they're telling me to wrap
up but thank you so much congratulations
on the film have a great rest of your
day yeah you too thank you very much